encuentra el producto 4 x menos 5 x
menos 7.5 así que simplemente es un
producto de tres números algunos de los
cuales son positivos y algunos de los
cuales son negativos el orden no es
importante pero vamos a hacerlo de
izquierda a derecha vamos a hacer 4 x
menos 5 y el resultado por menos 7.5 así
que déjenme reescribir esto 4 x menos 5
x menos 7.5 este punto está de más
porque realmente el paréntesis ya me
indica que estoy multiplicando las cosas
ahora bien recordemos que un positivo
por un positivo nos da un positivo un
positivo por un negativo o un negativo
por un positivo sin son signos
contrarios nos da un negativo
y si tengo un negativo por negativo nos
da un positivo así que bien 4 por menos
54 por 5 sería 20 4 por 5 sería 20 pero
esto es un positivo por un negativo así
que esto es un número negativo así que
es menos 20 signos contrarios nos dan un
producto negativo y eso lo tengo que
multiplicar por menos 7.5 así que
primero vamos a averiguar cuántas 20 x
7.5 7.5 por 20 es cero por 500 por 70
bajo un cero y me recorro
ahora 2 por 5 es 10 0 12 por 7 14 y el 1
que llevaba 15 ahora asumo esto 0 0 0 0
0 0 0 y 5 el 5 y 0 y 1 es1 ahora cuento
el número de dígitos que tengo después
del punto decimal solo tengo uno así que
solo lo pongo
un dígito después del punto decimal así
que 20 x 7.5 es 150 solo tengo que
averiguar si es positivo o negativo
tengo un negativo por un negativo así
que eso nos da un número positivo
así que la respuesta final es 150 en
realidad podría poner